bienvenue à moscou dans les bureaux de
radio canada qui se trouve au fait dans
un édifice à logements du gouvernement
russe ce qu'on a un gouvernement russe
qui 44 ans plus tard a ordonné la
fermeture du bureau du diffuseur public
canadien en guise de représailles
mettant fin à une tradition de
journalisme de terrain de rigueur et
d'indépendance
c'est une tragédie parce que
radio-canada et cybit six ans à moscou
depuis l'époque de l'urss alors on a
vécu sur place avaient des
correspondants
tous les grands événements de l'urss et
la russie depuis ces années alors c'est
toute une mémoire c'est tout un regard
expert ouvert en 1978 le bureau de siby
si radio canada a accueilli une dizaine
de correspondants qui ont rapporté la
réalité d'un pays au territoire immense
et aux crises politiques majeures
raymond st-pierre la sillonner depuis
1985 avant de devenir correspondant 2015
d'abord il y eut le coup d'état nous 91
contre gorbatchev
qui a été vraiment le début de la fin
c'est là qu'on s'est rendu compte y
avait des divisions profondes en union
soviétique
malgré les raids aériens constants de
petites unités de combattants
tchétchènes s'en est suivie la
dislocation de l'urss qui s'est fait
dans la rébellion et le sens des
événements rapporter fidèlement par nos
correspondants
mais du bloc soviétique à la russie de
vladimir poutine être un journaliste
étranger n'a jamais été facile
une sorte de harcèlement puis détention
véritable mais c'était encore villa on
apprend à vivre avec ça
[Musique]
pour alexandra schatz cas il fallait
surtout composer avec la propagande
russe dans un pays où la frontière entre
médias étatiques et public est
inexistante la propagande est à l'oeuvre
- elle est un peu partout mais elle
était beaucoup plus à l'heure des
mensonges des mauvaises informations
alors il fallait vraiment fouiller
beaucoup beaucoup pour trouver vérifier
les informations qu'on avait quel sera
le prochain geste que posera vladimir
poutine c'est le rideau de fer qui tombe
sur sur la russie et on n'a plus besoin
que jamais de l'information véritable de
sur ce qui se passe là-bas sur le ce que
dit la population russe malgré la
répression des manifestations ne
correspondent en témoignent d'une
jeunesse russe qui recherche la vérité
[Musique]
ce qui m'a beaucoup émue moi ceux de
voir combien les jeunes ont décidé de
prendre la rue et protester contre ce
régime parce qu'ils ont connu rien
d'autre que les années poutine ait eu
n'écoute pas les médias officiels qui
reste une jeunesse si elle ne part pas
tout à l'étranger il ya une jeunesse qui
va quand même faire évoluer ce pays là
un moment donné poutine ne soit pas
éternel ici au smic rail est radio
canada montréal